create
every create every damn day yes okay
that's that's a saying you have on your
Twitter I believe that's right it's on
my Twitter and my Instagram and I think
I even used to have it in my email
signature but now it's just Social House
films how is that possible to create
every day is it possible I mean it's
it's absolutely possible and it doesn't
you don't need to be like created like
finishing a screenplay every day but you
can outline something you can even write
like one scene that you're really
excited about that you see very clearly
in your head you could even you know
whip out the camera and try and just do
a little bit of something you know
whatever it is that's speaking to you
whatever's like calling to your creative
heart that day that's the best day ever
seriously and even if you're not
feelingly creative like I would
challenge people to just either take out
a pen and paper or their laptop or their
phone depending on whatever whatever
your thing is and just try to create
something and just keep going until
you've made something and even if it's
not great you got tomorrow because
you're you're going to create again
tomorrow and there's just this feeling
of accomplishment to some degree there's
a feeling of growth you know you've
tried something maybe even outside of
your comfort level and if you keep doing
that it's just like investing or Fitness
like every day you're just putting in a
little bit of time you're putting in a
little bit more investment and you're
getting better without even realizing it
and you're like nourishing your soul so
it's really fun a lot of people might
have said well that sounds great but I
don't have time I'm working for jobs
especially here in La everybody's got
these different gig jobs what would be
your answer to that
you know I am definitely not a stranger
to working multiple jobs before I moved
out to LA I was uh doing all types of
like gig Works where you just any job
that would come up I had a little diary
and I was like yep I need the money
let's go and I totally get it sometimes
you actually can't uh have the time or
even the resources to you know maybe get
final draft or Celtics or what what have
you right to start crafting your your
craft but I think you can even create in
your mind I think I also think I sound
very nerdy that way but some of my best
times have just been like thinking
brainstorming about new scenes or new
ideas and really trying to visualize
that entire scene or or script play out
in my mind and even then I I feel even
if nothing has been committed to paper
or digital I still feel like cool that
was really good I dig it and I I feel
accomplished for that day so no matter
what even if you are a gig worker you
feel really busy I mean everyone thinks
right everyone's like up there in their
brain spending some time so why not try
and be creative when you're up there and
one thing about G jobs from having
worked in myself is that you're driving
from one to the other and sometimes your
car is like your little house for the
day exactly your changing got your
snacks you got your music and your water
and maybe an outfit change depending on
the job you're going to um but you you
know you always have a little bit of
time in your brain to to start thinking
creatively and even like like check out
someone else in the car and see what
they're up to and kind of try and
envision what they're life is like
because they have this whole complex
world going on and that's inspiration
for some for something you can create in
your mind so I think it's all as long as
you're just allowing yourself to have
that flexibility and and play and try
and create you're doing it so be be kind
to yourself and just just let yourself
run wild with the creativity what
happens if two days go by and you
haven't created anything Victoria
they're sad
days um if if that happens you know that
that and that does happen because you
get busy you certainly as much as it's
as fun as it is to play you know
imagination you have life like things
that you need to uh commit yourself to
so I completely understand that don't
the best thing you can do is just start
as soon as you're able start today if
you can start the next morning don't
beat yourself up about what you can do
the past two days start tomorrow start
fresh and if you can't pick a day the
next day off where you can actually do
something and and try and challenge
yourself just a little bit you know it's
okay it's certainly okay to spend the
time in your brain meditating or just
you know brainstorming but if you can if
you have the time to just at least put
something on paper just make something a
little B more tangible that you can
really like look at this piece of work
that I created it's a huge pat on the
back and it makes you feel much better
for skipping a couple days have you ever
shown your work to someone and received
praise and then another time maybe shown
your work and not received praise yes
and how did both affect your future work
oh gosh I'll I'll keep name you know of
course keep names out of out of things
but this this happened to me recently
and and it was it was actually a really
rough day
because so I I received some feedback on
a piece of work and you know maybe like
one two three people who are all close
friends gave really kind feedback they
said they really loved it um and but you
know you always wonder like you're my
friend are you just being polite or and
then there was the fourth friend who uh
I have no idea if he liked it or not
because he gave me quite a bit of notes
um and that's totally fine because
that's life and that's how we get better
I also uh as Aaron would say like to
like filter things so you try and you
filter everything all the good and the
bad you take what you can and then try
and filter out what you don't need
that's in a perfect world because the ne
I read the comments I read them late
late at night went to bed I didn't sleep
that well the next day I was just like
down in the dumps eore I couldn't quite
put my finger on what was wrong with me
and I mean that's just life like people
aren't always going to like what I come
up with I completely understand that but
for some reason this one particular like
feedback of of notes I was like this
thing I created is trash what was
thinking you know and I was totally hard
on myself um and then really what I did
to get out of that was I just talked to
Aaron about it I said you know Aaron is
my business partner and my love partner
um and so I I lean on him quite a bit
for just all all types of feelings and
Creations and so um I told him how I was
feeling and he was like yeah totally
understand what we create isn't always
going to be for everyone we are going to
get so much more feedback in the future
some people are going to like it some
people are going to destroy it so we
just have to be confident what we're
creating know that the vision that we're
setting out is what we intended to make
and just be proud of it as best as we
can be that was that was that eventually
got me out of it I think I was probably
still a little sad for like six or six
or seven more hours and then eventually
I you know went to bed and I was much
better the next
day yeah well that's that's a good place
to get to it sounds like um you get like
a muscle almost yeah you know if if
people don't like it so yeah ites it
certainly doesn't feel good but it's so
needed you know you actually I think
it's like practice you know I'm still a
very small scale independent filmmaker
and producer I hope to be a big scale
one and I can't imagine what it's going
to be like when you know you're getting
these major maybe it's Hollywood
Reporter and indiewire whatever they're
writing you up and possibly shredding
your work shredding work that maybe you
worked three four years on or more you
know you're lucky if it's only three or
four years um and I mean that must be
really gut-wrenching for a lot of
creators but I think that now while
we're still in like a smaller formative
level I take it as a lesson it's like
okay okay this is a muscle like like I
have to get used to people not liking it
it's not always going to feel good
sometimes I'm going to have bad days but
just move on just take what you can move
to the Future that's that did you see
the hillbilly elegy I did did you like
it I did yeah yeah I loved it I thought
it was excellent and I actually want to
watch it again but I understand that
some people had strong opinions about it
yeah I was surprised I have no idea why
I watched it I mean I I feel like maybe
there was like a little bit of political
undertone that rubbed some people the
wrong way but I by no means I'm from
that uh part of the country but I'm from
a town that's smaller you know less
connected we had our own difficulties
you know in my Southern Maryland
Hometown and you know you kind of you
you see parts of your own self in a
story like that and I see that person
who tried their best to like lift thems
out of the area that they weren't happy
with his name is uh Vance uh JD Vance J
fance exactly um you know and I think
that's so inspiring that those are the
stories I want to watch where somebody
thems out they saw that something that
wasn't working for them they lifted
thems out and they went after their
passion and they they worked hard and
they got it I think that's fantastic and
I love that they made a movie about I
love Ron Howard and I'm like I loved it
I hope that people are a little Kinder
in the criticisms about it um also I
know how much work goes into a creation
like this so I I hope to never ever
shred a film that's beautifully done
like that because it's a lot of
work